happy December reject nation Greg here
you might have heard me mention this
many times at our patreon page to do
weekly Q&A s and we also do a lot of TV
show reactions some are stream alongs
and then there are other shows where we
have the streaming options from lobbying
you sync it with a timecode but then
also we do reaction highlights for those
and those shows our attack on titan my
hero academia movie included Death Note
Code Geass Hunter hunter and several
other shows actually but the main drive
of our patreon page is actually
supernatural even though our
supernatural reactions are exclusive for
patreon this episode is a Christmas
episode that I've saved in our editing
program for several months were actually
well ahead of this episode but I was
like when December rolls around I just
want to share this one episode reaction
up on YouTube YouTube only allows for 10
minute reaction highlights to be
included here a full length reaction
stream belongs for Supernatural and the
reaction highlights cuts for all the
other episodes starting at season two or
over our patreon page just wanted to
share this one specifically on YouTube
hope you guys enjoy Christmas is my
favorite scary time of the year that's
where you have to deal with emotional
repressed problems and have to get
intimate with family and have [ __ ]
conversations and make life seem like
it's better than it actually is and then
have them approve of the one you're
dating same time have them approve of
your lifestyle choices chills down my
spine let's watch this
[Music]
[Laughter]
what you know what Santa get Massacre Oh
maybe oh no it's gonna be Krampus yeah
probably
or maybe it's just a vengeful Santa
being live why are you impersonated you
must get head to lunch yeah not maybe
this is the year he snapped he's like
I'm tired of this it's gonna be Sam and
Dean get off me Dean not queer
[Music]
definitely dealing with Santa Claus here
I don't believe it
Santa Claus is real Sam that's what this
episodes really about yeah believe in
magic holiday people that's why it's
Christmas learn the truth do you ever
talk about mom
you know what you know what yeah this
gotta be miss Lee wow you are you work
with the pedophile you know that's
what's you over the time a yellow you
dressed about my hates Christmas not bad
it's got to be a movie or she's really
into it
mr. gung ho Christmas might have to blow
away Santa Wow right and you were right
Oh
[Laughter]
Oh that was painful singing
oh poor kid it's gonna be like that
Tales from the Crypt episode
Oh God
poor kid Wow least they have someone to
save huh yes well yeah because there's a
lot of these lures involved them like
taking you back to some cave or whatever
oh dude this is brutal
yeah sensors on the CW must be really
chill I just a lot you can do it's sound
design and reactions oh yeah they could
be very in here with you oh damn
he's puncher why aren't real cops
getting involved I think they'd have run
into one bite or like had to cross tape
or something oh dude anyone ask for
better shoes that's awesome nice
handbags my boy where the Walshes
yesterday
I know I'm just testing you D they use
meadowsweet for human sacrifices
pretty much every Christmas tradition is
pagan Christmas is Jesus birthday know
Jesus's birthday was probably in the
fall it was actually the winter solstice
festival that was co-opted by the church
and renamed Christmas by me the you
along the tree even Santa's retsu
there's all remnants of pagan worship
we're not watching this show anymore
what deal was blasphemy
the Pope's would my last Christ I mean
since what do you behave as be all of a
sudden why do you want to do Christmas
so bad last man come on Sam you should
have picked up on that yeah you're like
here all the episodes who's watched so
far
you're mr. perceptive mm-hmm that's
wacky I just can't
everything key to defeating the demon is
you gotta celebrate Christmas it's gonna
be a real Scrooge lesson here Christmas
always in your heart you don't shut up
that guy playing Dean when it growed up
to be
ROI from the office ha ha the dad from
brightburg yep that's where everybody
knows her father because he already
checked under there
damn little Sam you started this
conversation off like you were like
cocky for knowing this [ __ ] and he knows
it know what happens when you go find
your presence it really I was well
written well Samuel waldina pretty good
well your reason sold out before we got
the chance to buy all the wreaths are
fine vine wreaths
yeah care for some peanut brittle
they're way too step 13
so what Ozzie and Harriet or keeping a
pagan god hidden underneath their
plastic-covered couch he's sure
evergreen snakes will kill this thing
right yeah hell yeah and you got a rap a
string of Christmas lights around her
first sprig of Holly on top this is
where they keep the presents oh is it an
eyeball
yeah it's gonna move or sort of making
noise Oh people are gonna calm down
they had watch a hundred percent
accurate prediction hook hooks man what
they make hooks look so evil made oh wow
ah I was half right yeah it just
happened really fast very slowly we
should call it even and go our separate
ways
what's it bring back more hunters and
kill us you know when I see when I feel
like swimming to me get a budget kill
you
Wow kind of artery Oh
oh wow I was not expecting to see that
ah-ha I can't tell evilly oh no one gave
a [ __ ] at the CW it said some [ __ ] god
please we bother yourself it
Oh oh hey they just suddenly figured out
how to break in better to do it off
camera it's being like yeah you know
rope they probably figured out that rope
oh I still feel it violin Christmas
[Laughter]
[Music]
sweet little wires
open all you like steal some weather
kids look I swear I didn't know they
were check presents don't say that wait
15 to 20 years I Got News for you
oh ha ha oh that's cool
has he always had that neck yeah I think
I think so
I'm addressed the same for the rest
nation yeah we are fully formed
characters by the age of 7 or whatever
we 7 and 12 yeah I remember the rest of
my memory yeah it took me a while to to
get a new name egg
yeah
yeah I can actually use these do for me
and cool for my baby
oh these are oils and things what he got
one of my very favorite candy bars he
got a zagnut I didn't ask what would you
ever said something probably it's just
taking it in for a moment I'm never
gonna forget this now it's time to get
emotionally into me guys yeah watch the
game absolutely nice and they use the
original version of the song with the
bittersweet lyrics
I'd say do something spooky and r-rated
and still feel like a Christmas episode
movie I'm like you're [ __ ] lethal
weapon diehard I my favorite episode on
both counts
- I love the you know mystery of the
week element and you know they managed
to go someplace that you know you're
sitting here going it's probably some
kind of evil Sam - right then you're
like are no Krampus and then they went
it leads to a place that I hadn't been
thinking of but that always gets brought
up around Christmastime which is like
the pagan roots and stuff and then yeah
that's all false Jesus Jesus December 20
Jesus 100 Jesus maximum maximum over
yeah I even learned that in Catholic
school hmm
out of Catholic teacher didn't teach me
that and I believe it was like a science
teacher you know what I'm gonna tell you
guys well and I like that they went that
like I guess I was really probably
expecting her creature yeah so I really
like that they went that direction well
yeah I mean so it's the it was the guy
who's like going up and grabbing people
sleeping people up from the chimneys
that's what I kind of gathered there a
little bit the one or or else they
summon this you know Leif faced Santa
man so yeah come well I really like this
episode because they did exactly what I
was joking about when this end it is
they managed to do a supernatural
episode but really have this Christmas
bow around it and which I was really
impressed by because that the the first
time you check in on the the youth the
young Sam and Dean I thought was cheesy
yeah I'm like angry young Dean yeah but
then you're checking with that memory
three more times and
as it PreCheck in the second time I
really thought the the chemistry and the
writing of it was very heartfelt yeah
and I like the the subtlety of even the
adult interactions between Sam and Dean
when they're sitting in the hotel and
then Dean's talking about why he wants
to celebrate Christmas and like there's
this very specific meaning to this
episode because this could very well we
know it's not but it very well could be
you know Dean's last Christmas and then
having that thought of Sam pick up on
that and you go oh Sam has a very
specific reason why he's not addressing
or participating in the possibility of
celebrating and because he doesn't say
yes exactly reason yeah yeah reaction to
it and I like the the subtlety of their
performance when they are sitting in
that hotel room how they're afraid to
make eye contact with each other or
really dive deep into like the emotional
weight of the situation well their
interplay was great yeah it was
wonderful throughout and the mystery was
something you said a lot something like
figure out the mysteries mysteries this
this definitely took a different
direction beyond creature and I even
thought like the you know that happened
having fun with evil Santa coming in and
kidnapping people and killing or
whatever I thought was really
well-executed that one day you really
focused on was so subtle and simply
there's simple how they executed it yet
it was one of the more standout moments
I think of this show in terms of making
something truly
unnerving grounding it in the little
kids perspective and shooting it that
way it just enhances how like horrifying
but also like uncomfortable and
traumatic this must be you know like it
really ramps it up and it scene it makes
not seeing it worse yeah yeah because
it's left to be you're feeling what the
kids feeling you know like you hear that
punch to his mom in the bedroom and then
just watching the body being dragged
it's like you're not seeing a body
dradis I followed blood but there's it
it's that strange
twisting something that is normally like
some beautiful child fantasy but making
something so twisted would he's tracking
down one of his parents and one of the
Santa bag and then going to hype
dragging him down the stairs and hitting
him and this is the sound effects in the
reaction of that I thought was so on a
technical horror level that was so well
executed yeah and then even you get to
the old couple these pagan gods I'd like
them the the mythos built from it and I
thought the old people were fantastic
Horrors they were so damn good they were
so excellent like every reaction of
theirs was net was the way they did that
whole performance was completely
different then I feel like most actors
would have gone with it even as
something as like when they get the
fruitcake and the door opens the door
opens they get the fruitcake they lie
but then when the door shuts it's not
just like you know they don't just [ __ ]
you know it's not like they have a
reaction to that moment and they get
back to business
they get back they get back to business
in a way that didn't seem generic yeah
it's not just go back to Ceres for evil
you know like they still have the smiles
going and everything kind of you had
yeah Stephanie cake here you're still
enjoying their rich rule much more than
that fruitcake and I was so like you
know I don't know if this is in
reference to it you know but lethal
weapon is often argued as being a
Christmas movie this had their buddy-cop
dynamic Sam and Dean especially in this
episode and lethal weapon one they both
get captured and are very much more
chert and I didn't know if there was in
some way referencing that either way I
was pretty taken aback by whoa they were
good they're really committed to the
violence it was smart to show the shade
of the of the nail phone because I mean
that's teeth like those teeth pull and
nail poles are the two things I just had
on the stand that I can't look like that
and like ankles lashes
like those things I can't stand so
phantom pain so when they show that nail
pole
my god but but that also sets you up to
when that when they're gonna go for the
Dean to to like oh my god
oh my goodness yeah there's very yeah
superintendent and also yeah very I
liked how there was a nice unexpected
turn to me that the yeah flashbacks
become an important part of the whole
kind of foundation of their relationship
and telling a story about a significant
Christmas together and you know the
little lie that Dean sets up about like
dad totally showed up and then you know
he steals the wrong presents and stuff
like that like I thought this episode
managed to juggle kind of three stories
you know cuz the flashbacks of a story
yeah like just feels complete yeah yeah
yeah this feels oddly like a perfect
little Christmas movie you know that you
get a really you know you get I thought
it was a nice touch that they used the
song from me me and st. Louis have
yourself a merry little Christmas and
they used the lyrics to that song had
been changed over the years to make it
brighter but in that movie it's used
during a time during a really angsty
scene where you know a big life change
is coming on to those characters and
they're in a troubled spot and so I
thought that was also like I wouldn't be
surprised if there was lethal weapon'
tribute in here I thought about on Tales
from the Crypt when the Santa the big
Santa sequence is happening so I wonder
like if those you know things are
intended as well because yeah I love
that this struck a heartfelt but also
kind of bittersweet tone you know it's
her not exactly the flavor I feel like
you expect a certain amount of uplift
and I thought they did a nice sort of
not too dysfunctional but not too
chipper version of a Christmas story
you know yeah and there's also I think
like just a sprinkling of It's a
Wonderful Life just because of Dean well
they managed to have without it being
cheesy which I which really surprises me
especially with having I think because
when you set up the relationship between
Dean
Sam and Dean of where they're at with
how they relate to Chris's and I and I
feel like you know even for someone like
myself for most of my life I feel like
lately and I don't get in this dark in a
mood as I used to but usually around
Christmas for a majority of my life I am
one of those people who often would get
like like overwhelmingly depressed
around the holidays so happen there's a
there's a certain element there that
nature to react that way it's
Christmastime and the time of holiday
and Cheer and yet you know overwhelming
depression kind of the way Sam's
reacting to it which I thought was a
really cool relatable element to have
and then with starting off the dynamics
of they're not comfortable with
Christmas they're not comfortable with
the bond and the celebration of it so
when they get to that final moment which
ties in nicely with the flash I just I
do love that structure just like he was
just taking break from remembering like
all the scenes where they're not
investigating he's just sitting there
remember I don't think that's exactly
what yeah in the placement of the
narrative it is very very intentional it
seems yeah well you get sort of these
core memories that have really shaped
their early on dynamics of of Dean
viewing his dad as a hero as a really
young guy a young young lad yeah and
then Sam feeling neglected and abandoned
kind of you know on the outside of the
situation looking in yeah yeah
definitely good way to put it and then
you have that moment with the necklace
which I thought was I love that probably
the most that was it was like it was
heartfelt
without ham fisting anything and I
really felt like this could have ended
on some like cheesy it's like so there's
love very Christmas now but even even
the way how they exchanged the gifts and
now and how they choose to celebrate you
can tell they're not entirely
comfortable with this and there
just trying to have a good time and
celebrate yeah it's truly a fight that
counts really like realistic and for
these two characters on how they would
celebrate Christmas these circumstances
it and also a factor on the [ __ ] they
just went through
yeah totally one and not just a purely
kind of personal taste note like that's
got to be if all the of all the
easter-egg moments of like oh this is
where that small detail came from like
this felt completely natural and like a
great opportunity on a Christmas episode
whereas like so many other things feel
like randomly needlessly explained and
so like this this episode like covers a
lot of ground that could potentially be
cheesy and it really managed to avoid
that every time yeah like I'm very
impressed this is my favorite episode
from this and they still did a great job
of like reported us out last time of
managing to keep it sir realized with
you know by doing a monster of the week
doing a Christmas episode prefer of the
year yet having this be an integral
moment to the development of their
relationship based off the circumstances
of Dean's gonna die you know so I'm
really glad they've committed to having
that be the through-line for every
episode yeah because I feel like that
could have been earlier on I thought
that could have become something that's
sort of a repetitive just like this is
our character no but I feel like it has
become something fully integrated into
the characters and in a lived-in sort of
way yeah it causes them to have some
introspect into the way how they would
normally handle or react or deal with
sort of situations it it automatically
creates different perspectives knowing
this is like the last time we might have
this yeah so it changes the dynamic of
how they view any of what it's normally
part of the job it changes it so yeah
this has been great
whose awesome I'm Halloween yet acquired
thank you guys